hey Vsauce Michael here on December 17th
1977 Gary Gilmore was executed for
murder
he was the first prisoner executed by
the United States after a 10-year
suspension of the practice when asked if
he had any last words he simply replied
let's do it
leaders later advertising executive Dan
Wyden adapted those words into a slogan
that is now more widely known than Gary
Gilmore last words are powerful they are
the final statement a person's entire
life has been leading up to one last
chance to go on record before
obliteration we don't know Albert
Einstein's last words he spoke them in
German to a nurse who only knew English
they're lost but what will be our first
words the first words from Earth
extraterrestrials out there might hear
from us we have been broadcasting
signals with radio waves wirelessly
through the air for more than 100 years
under the right conditions those signals
can leak into space and keep going
outward at the speed of light through
our galaxy through the universe current
human technology would struggle to tune
into regular TV and radio broadcasts
from as near as Mars but perhaps other
intelligent beings out there would fare
better and could point their instruments
at earth and hear us if so what would
the earliest thing be that they could
receive our cosmic first words well the
earliest signal robust enough to be
picked up light-years away might have
come from Hitler his 1936 broadcasting
of the Summer Olympics used powerful
enough radio equipment to reach 41
countries making it a contender for what
listening extraterrestrials could
receive
as to them Earth's first words within
the last 50 years or so broadcast
signals in general have become stronger
than Hitler's Olympics and are better
candidates for being intercepted the
earliest of them have travelled 50
light-years away from Earth altogether
they have entertained billions of people
and by now about 2,000 stars the 133
brightest of which are shown here so far
Martin Luther King Junior's I have a
dream speech has traveled as far as the
farthest on the diagram mu era which has
four known planets in six years our
first words on the moon will pass by mu
eras system those words were spoken by
Neil Armstrong seen here a few years
before his death with Eugene Cernan the
most recent and currently last man to
have walked on the surface of the Moon
on December 14th 1972 before climbing
back into the lunar module
Cernan spoke our as of today last words
on the moon we leave as we came and God
willing as we shall return with peace
and hope for all mankind of course once
inside the lunar module the crew kept
talking meaning that technically the
very last words humans have said on the
surface of the moon were a countdown
spoken by Harrison Jack Schmitt we
haven't been back to the moon since but
hold on what were the first words spoken
on the surface of the Moon really
Armstrong's giant leap statement is a
good answer but what counts as being on
the moon if touchdown counts then the
first word spoken on the moon
not to Armstrong but to Buzz Aldrin who
on feeling at least one of the landing
pads softly settle onto the lunar soil
spoke this immortal description our back
right contact light we are pumping
broadcasts into space as an ever
expanding sphere of radio waves but
here's something humbling even while
growing at the speed of light
Earth's radio sphere is puny this is our
galaxy the Milky Way comparatively the
distance our radio signals our voice has
traveled is this big
[Music]
the universe is huge how the heck are
you supposed to be remembered in it
utter last words that stick around after
you die well you may have heard the
famous quote from Banksy they say you
die twice one time when you stop
breathing and a second time a bit later
on when somebody says your name for the
last time but your anonymous influence
continues long after that right
I mean people may stop saying your name
but for instance if you have kids and
they have kids and so on and so on you
continue on in a way maybe just
genetically not by name well people have
tried the world record for most children
passed out of one single woman belongs
to mrs. Theodore Vasilyev she had 16
pairs of twins 7 sets of triplets and 4
sets of quadruplets for a grand total of
69 children as for being a biological
father that takes less time the
documented record for most children
fathered by one man is held by his ma
he'll even Sharif who is estimated to
have had more than 900 children with
multiple women but children or not in a
feedback system like Earth or life cause
and effect are complicated and
never-ending remember the double
pendulums from this video a small
difference in the initial conditions of
a system can lead to enormous ly
different outcomes later on Tuesday I'm
flying from London to Los Angeles the
plane will be flown by pilots who can
steer it toward the correct runway in
the United States but if the airplane
needed to be aimed from London and sent
on a straight shot now things would need
to be very specific miss aiming just one
degree to the left at the beginning
would send the plane not to Los Angeles
but nearly a hundred
the kilometers south to Tijuana Mexico
your name and your last words might
eventually be forgotten but your status
as an initial condition for the
universe's future is already happening
Bach died before he could complete the
art of fugue the piece ends abruptly
during contra punctus 14 so composers
continue reconstructing it for that
reason it is uniquely alive speaking new
last words all the time as new people
meet it and finish it in their own way
likewise no matter how cool or lame and
small you feel you will continue your
impact will be remembered mathematics
guarantees it even if like Bach you
leave things unfinished and as always
thanks for watching